[موسيقى]
المشهد في في الغرب او في الشرق تطور
بتطور بشكل كبير في العالم العربي ولله
الحمد مشاهده نقلات يعني جدا كبيره خلال
العشر سنوات السابقه وطبعا العالم العربي
يعني منطقه جغرافيه كبيره لما نتكلم عن
العالم العربي نتكلم عن بلدان مختلفه
بعضها خطط خطوات جدا ممتازه لدعم رياده
الاعمال والصناديق الاستثماريه ونذكر على
راس القائمه السعوديه والامارات ومصر وهي
اتت بالفعل على راس القائمه في حجم
التمويلات التي تمت في عام
لذلك اجابه على سؤالك استاذه منتهى الرحله
ليست سهله شاقه في البلدان المتطوره وفي
في بلدان العالم العربي
[موسيقى]
مستثمرين في
صراع دائما مع انفسهم للبحث عن افضل
الفرصه المتاحه وكذلك يعني بكل تاكيد هم
مقتنعين انه في نهايه المطاف
مستحيل انهم يدخلوا في كل الفرص احنا
دائما نقول يعني يعني المجال اللي احنا
فيه عباره عن
الشركات فاحنا نقول لا لعدم الاستثمار
اكثر مما يقول نعم للاستثمار لانه نعم
غالبا تتم لعدد محدد من الشركات بناء على
زي مثلا ذكرنا قبل قليل على مجال عامل
الصندوق والتركيز الجغرافي اللي يركز
عليها الصندوق وكذلك ايمان الشركاء في
الصندوق بالفرصه ومن الممكن جدا انه يعني
بعض الفرص تضيع على المستثمر وهذه احد
قواعد اللعبه
[موسيقى]